[Musique]
on termine ce journal par les principaux
résultats sportifs du week-end avec
michael et demi d'euros bonsoir
journalistes aux sports de la rédaction
de tv 78 on va commencer par du football
et on jouait la coupe de france ce
week-end le 7e tour de la coupe de
france même versailles dernier club
yvelinois en lice continue l'aventuré
versailles et sont revenus de leur
voyage à la réunion avec une victoire
dans leur valise se sont imposés 3-2
contre l' us sainte marie les hommes de
la cité royale revenue au score à deux
reprises ont marqué dans les dernières
minutes du temps additionnel sur penalty
à la 95e minute de jeu regarde la
réaction dans les vestiaires
[Applaudissements]
le tirage au sort du prochain tour aura
lieu cette semaine la rencontre soit
programmé le samedi 7 ou le dimanche 8
décembre
on croise les doigts on continue à
parler football un petit peu les
divisions plus basse le championnat de
première division de district avec un
choc qui étaient au programme où ils ont
été sortis de la coupe de france très
tôt dans la compétition voisins et
gargenville deux équipes dans le top 3
de la division s'affronter ce dimanche
le 17 novembre sur le terrain de
voisins-le-bretonneux après une phase
d'observation la première période et
finalement remporté par les visiteurs
gargenville marque deux buts en contre 2
à 0 à la mi-temps en deuxième période
voisin poussent pour revenir au score
ce sont finalement les joueurs de
gargenville qui creuse l'écart avec un
troisième but 3 0 ce sera le score final
on écoute la réaction de ioana michely
seconde mi temps c'était mieux on a
commencé à rentrer dans notre compte
malheureusement ça faisait 45 minutes le
match avait débuté mais bon c'était
c'était beaucoup mieux
après on a un peu manqué d'efficacité
puis on prend un but dans les arrêts de
jeu un peu anecdotique pour rebondir à
voisins bretons ne tentera de s'imposer
sur le terrain de bois d'arcy le
dimanche 24 novembre de son côté et
gargenville se rendra sur le terrain de
sartrouville là on termine par du
cyclisme pendant la soirée à deux galas
star en piste organisé au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
spectateurs ont notamment pu assister à
un record philippon c'est un sportif
atteint de broncho-pneumopathie
chronique obstructive les maladies de
poumon a réussi à parcourir plus de 27,1
kilomètres sous assistance respiratoire
objectif sensibiliser le grand public
sur sa maladie qui touche 4 millions de
personnes en france s'en retrouvera un
caucus un peu plus générale avec des
interviews aussi sur cet évènement
michael dans votre émission de 7,8 sport
c'est à suivre dans quelques instants
sur tv 78